hi I'm Greg and Morgan Morgan okay is
when life hands you Morgan on Instagram
youtube.com then you type in how to
choose the Morgan eventually if they
don't have the URL you remember that yet
hey Morgan I'm half Filipino okay so a
few weeks ago I did a video reaction to
a Filipino commercials that I ended up
being like amazing short films okay and
they made me both oh and then I watched
moshing like one a week for the past few
weeks they are the most emotional
commercials you'll ever see I just drink
ever watched a couple of scary videos we
did let's let's see if we can touch I
don't know if this is going to make me
cry
the video is called your touches enough
mom these are commercial like Johnson
and Johnson's baby wipes yeah we don't
know hey if you anticipate crying you
usually don't Ellen I want to cry I want
to cry I got a lot of requests a lot of
requests for this Dan Garcia the first
one i screen shot out of it
[Music]
[Music]
what's happening to her baby
[Music]
I almost died ah ah
[Music]
that's adorable
[Music]
I'm a little teary and I'm gonna lie I
want Oh a little Asian baby precious how
these commercials have this like random
emotional time committee yeah can't you
hear Han what's wrong
that's why these commercials they always
have it would sound like this nice set
up of things and then here's a little
emotional twist on it that when she ran
to the baby yeah why are you running he
was crying she must have been like oh oh
you aren't you she always look so
worried ah like she's like a single
death mom that warms my heart for real
my kid's gonna be nice learn to speak
but I didn't how cool she has to sleep
battling good - that would be so cool
plus she can sign but that says Saturday
yeah cool
yeah who would teaching the talk school
teacher talking - you can myself that's
so sweet
oh man I mean - nah I can't imagine not
being able to hear my mom's voice like I
know my mom you know like you you know
you know your mom's boys you could just
hear it when you imagine it yeah and I
can't imagine that and as the whole I
connect at that end moment when she's
like crying and then he touched her
something like she touches his face yeah
got it
like mom my one of my love language is
touch here the five languages of love
yes if that voice doesn't everybody have
that organizational will do the ability
of some people hate it I want to know
what line it I have to death test
Harry's rebut they are than you I want
you to know there you go when you go yet
I think I'm hearing I don't know
it's space you know whatever like Asian
women crave my mom's the Filipino one in
the family so when an Asian woman cries
I just remember the few times I've seen
my mom cry so that's what time it gets
to me it's like this subconscious reflex
it shoots to my eyeballs that gets the
watery oh yeah if my mom's one of those
likes it's like she's like her she's a
strong woman she's doing what she can't
just doing her best to take care of her
children but every once in while he's a
big crime it's like they they try not to
but they those are like real tears for a
lot of people where they're trying not
to cry but oh yeah that's my most
authentic yeah I'm not a crier either so
if she cries in his life yeah yeah I'm
doing this renewal hug my mom later I'm
not my mom later yeah everyone should
hug your mom yeah unless she's a [ __ ]
hunger anyway maybe your husband her
heart yeah or he abandon you then you
got to ask yourself what did you do to
deserve that find her and then hunt it
and then ask her why did you do that to
me Mom so you can understand what you
did wrong to be a band sorry I know it's
we're I talking about here conversation
form is such a great we love our mother
they abandon us cos we're terrible we
just had to go to darker Joe territory
I'm sorry I'm sorry
the document is fine this makes you want
to buy Johnson's baby wipes or powder
I'm use our lavender lotion
is it good mm-hmm it's not well avender
is you would think it's more baby lotion
II well I bet that still moisturizes and
softens the skin yeah yeah so go out
there and get a johnson's lavender
lavender lavender nighttime baby lotion
their boys are baby oils good to Johnson
baby oil or baby wipes whenever you poop
huh because we all like to clean yeah I
don't use toilet paper toilet paper
certain babies
[Laughter]
stars brilliancy comedy your little baby
way and then as you get older it's
preparation-h wife so you know so it
goes full circle baby way preparation
and Johnson's baby powder baby powder I
use that too it's a good moisturizer I
use it at the beach baby powder on a
towel get sand off of you without you
being around the mangroves no I was
lucky are you sunscreen I use Johnson's
baby powder really might happen like
that's why your little pale nice free
kalitta the beach rubber I go in a wave
cloud and I walk through here well
that's lovely looks quite lovely thank
you
well you can subscribe to the real
rejects I'm Greg
Morgan Morgan when life hands you Morgan
mm-hmm on Instagram how to's with Morgan
and Ashley on YouTube and have two
blondes make a right on Instagram and
shout outs all you Filipinos who are
watching today
well let's go sing some karaoke sometime
we love our karaoke do that and our
journey hmm
a journey replaced their lead singer
with a Filipino guy did you know this
and we have Manny Pacquiao yeah yes we
do